ELECTION.
BUCKLE UP.
A LOT IN TONIGHT'S BREAKS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
SOME DEMOCRATS TURNED THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS INTO A
CIRCUS FOR 3 WEEKS.
THEY VILIFIED JUDGE KAVANAUGH
AND TRIED TO RUIN HIS LIFE.
TURNED AN ANGRY MOB AGAINST HIM.
THEY THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT MIGHT
GIVE UP.
BUT HE STOOD BY HIS NOMINEE AND
STOOD UP FOR THE CORE PRINCIPLES
OF OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
DUE PROCESS, THE CONSTITUTION,
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, AND
SIMPLE COMMON SENSE.
A HUGE RALLY IN IOWA THE
PRESIDENT CONGRATULATED THE
NEWEST MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT AND SO MUCH
MORE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YESTERDAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WE PROUDLY SWORE IN THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> TODAY JUSTICE KAVANAUGH TOOK
HIS SEAT ALONG SIDE OF JUSTICE
GORSUCH TO DEFEND YOUR RIGHTS,
YOUR CONSTITUTION AND YOUR GOD
GIVEN FREEDOM.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I WANT TO THANK OUR
INCREDIBLE REPUBLICAN SENATORS
FOR REFUSEING TO BACK DOWN IN
THE FACE OF THE DEMOCRATS
SHAMEFUL CAMPAIGN OF POLITICAL
AND PERSONAL DESTRUCTION.
>> [BOOING].
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THE
CROWD IN IOWA IS SICK OF
WINNING.
ON HIS FIRST DAY AS THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING.
HE BECAME THE SINGLE FIRST
MEMBER OF THE SUPREME COURT TO
HIRE AN ALL FEMALE STAFF OF LAW
CLERKS.
THE LEFT WAS EXPOSED.
THE HYPOCRISY AND THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA ARE NOT TAKING IT WELL.
IT REMINDS ME OF ELECTION NIGHT
2 YEARS AGO.
THE STATE IS OF SHOCK.
YOU CAN SHOCK THE WORLD IN 28
DAYS AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA OF HOLDING A VICTORY
RALLY LIKE THIS FOR JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH TO SAY THE COURT
SHOULD NOT BE PARTISAN BUT STAND
THERE AND THANK MAINLY
REPUBLICANS.
JOE MANCHIN GOT A SHOUT OUT FOR
HIS VOTE.
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
>> REMEMBER HIS DIVISIVE
LANGUAGE TONIGHT.
PROOF THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS OUR
DIVIDER IN CHIEF.
>> TIME AND AGAIN WHEN THE
PRESIDENT GETS A CHANCE TO HEAL
THE COUNTRY HE DOES JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
>> HOW WOULD YOU SUM UP WHAT YOU
SAW YESTERDAY HAPPENING IN THE
EAST ROOM AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> IT WAS GRACELESS SEAN.
>> Sean: WE WILL DISCUSS NIKKI
HALEY WHO ANNOUNCED HER
RESIGNATION.
AND THE DANA POWELL MAY REPLACE
HALEY.
MAJOR BREAKING NEWS ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE AND HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THIS DOSSIER PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC.
THEY FUNNELED MONEY THROUGH A
LAW FIRM.
IT WAS USED NOT FOR LAW BUT SENT
TO A RESEARCH FIRM CALLED FUSION
GPS.
THEY HIRED A FOREIGN NATIONAL, I
BY NAMED CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE DUG UP RUSSIAN DIRT ON DONALD
TRUMP.
STEELE SAID THE CONTENT IN THE
DOSSIER WERE UNVERIFIED.
IN GREAT BRITAIN UNDER THREAT OF
PERJURY STEELE REFUSED TO
STANDBY THE VALIDITY IN HIS OWN
DOSSIER GIVING IT A CONFIDENCE
RATING OF ONLY 50-50.
LAST WEEK LOST IN THE CHAOS OF
THE KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION, HE
LEARNED THAT A LAWYER WORKING
FOR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND THE
DNC FUNNELED THIS ANTI-TRUMP
RUSSIAN LIES TO THE TOP LAWYER
AT THE FBI JAMES BAKER IN 2016.
THIS ALL CAME OUT AS FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS PREPARED A WARRANT
FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
CARTER PAGE.
THAT WAS ALL BASED ON THE PHONEY
DOSSIER.
BAKER WHO YOU SEE THERE REVEALED
HIS EXCHANGE WITH CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS LAST WEDNESDAY.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING OU THIS PROGRAM.
WE HAVE CONFIRMATION.
A TOP LAWYER FOR THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
WORKING WITH THE TOP LAWYER AT
THE FBI TO SURVEIL A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE BASED ON
HILLARY'S PHONEY BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER.
IT'S THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION, SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
TONIGHT IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
COORDINATING TO THE SEPARATE
REPORTS.
CATHERRINE AND SARAH CARTER AND
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS SERIOUS WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT SURVEILING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HOPING HE MIGHT
GET INFORMATION THEY COULD
INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE HIM FROM OFFICE.
ROSENSTEIN R
ROSENSTEIN'S REMARKS WERE NOT
SAID IN GEST.
THIS WAS UNVEILED IN THE
DEPOSITION OF JAMES BAKER BEFORE
CONGRESS.
THAT CONFIRMS THE SEPTEMBER
REPORT FROM THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WHERE THEY REVEAL THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN HAD A PLOT TO SURVEIL
HIS BOSS DONALD TRUMP BEFORE WE
HEARD OF A SPECIAL COUNSEL OR
ROBERT MUELLER.
IT'S THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
McCABE, HIS ATTORNEY LISA PAGE,
THEY BOTH WITNESSED AND
CHRONICLED ROD ROSENSTEIN
TALKING ABOUT WEARINGA WIRE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS BEYOND TROUBLING.
WE KNOW ALL OF ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
OTHER CONFLICKS.
-- CONFLICTS.
SIGNED THE FINAL FISA WARRANT.
WE HAVE ONE MORE PIECE TO A
DISTURBING PUZZLE.
IT'S CLEAR THAT MEMBERS OF OUR
BUREAUCRACY WERE TRYING TO
DESTROY BOTH CANDIDATE AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN WHAT THEY
CALLED THEIR MEDIA LEAK
STRATEGY.
ALL OF THIS MEANS HILLARY IS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONEY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT WAS NEVER
CORROBORATED, USED TO GET FISA
WARRANTS, ALL OF THESE LIES TO
INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION AND
USED TO COMMIT A FRAUD ON FISA
BOARD JUDGES TO GET A WARRANT ON
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE.
AFTER ALL OF THAT FAILED.
DONALD TRUMP WINS.
THEN THE CONTENTS OF THE
UNVERIFIED PHONEY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER THAT HILLARY CLINTON
PAID FOR, THEY LEAKED IT TO
MEDIA OUTLETS.
SO ALL OF THE PHONEY NEWS WOULD
CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE WHEREBY
PEOPLE COULD CALL FOR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO BE APPOINTED.
JAMES COMEY LEAKED TO HIS
PROFESSOR FRIEND AT COLUMBIA.
THIS IS PLAIN, SIMPLE,
FUNDAMENTAL ABUSE OF POWER.
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE DOJ AND THE FBI.
IT SHREDS OUR 4TH AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS.
SARAH SMITH AND GREG JARRETT AND
CATHERRINE ARE HERE TONIGHT.
IN 28 DAYS WE THE PEOPLE WILL
DECIDE THE FATE OF YOUR
GOVERNMENT.
HILLARY CLINTON IS THROWING
HERSELF BACK INTO THE POLITICAL
FRAY.
SHE'LL MAKE A LOT OF MONEY DOING
SO.
DEMONIZING CONSERVATIVES.
WE ARE ALL IRREDEEMABLE, SMELLY
WAL-MART PEOPLE.
WE CLING TO GOD, GUNS, BIBLES
AND RELIGION.
THIS IS THE LATEST.
>> YOU CAN'T BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR, WHAT
YOU CARE ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE IF WE ARE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO WIN BACK THE
HOUSE AND/OR THE SENATE, THAT'S
WHEN CIVILITY CAN START AGAIN.
>> Sean: IN THE SEASON TIME, NO
CIVILITY.
WE HAVE ANGRY MOBS OF LEFT WING
PROTESTORS BLOCKING TRAFFIC.
PORTLAND'S LIBERAL MAYOR DID
ZERO TO STOP THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WATCH OUT YOU WHITE LITTLE
[BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> YOU ARE A WHITEY, AREN'T YOU?
GET THE [BLEEP] OUT OF HERE.
>> [BLEEP].
>> TURN RIGHT.
>> YOU ARE BLOCKING TRAFFIC.
>> YOU CAN TURN.
>> [SCREAMING].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [BLEEP].
[BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [SCREAMING].
>> HEY, HEY!
>> [BLEEP].
>> Sean: WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
SADLY IS NOTHING NEW.
WE SAW SIMILAR RESPONSE FROM FAR
LEFT ANTI-KAVANAUGH PROTESTORS
AND SAW REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS
CONFRONTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
RUN OUT OF RESTAURANTS.
PAM BONDI AND SARAH SANDERS AND
TED CRUZ AND MITCH MCCONNELL.
THEY ARE TOLD TO GET IN PEOPLE'S
FACE IN STORES AND GAS STATIONS.
IT'S HAPPENING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, ACCOMPANIED
BY AN EFFORT FROM ELECTED
DEMOCRATS TO DESTROY THE LIFE
AND CHARACTER OF JUDGE BRETT
KAVANAUGH BASED ON ZERO
CORROBORATION FROM 4 DECADES
AGO.
NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
IN 28 DAYS YOU CAN ELECT THE
PARTY OF SMEARS, SLANDERS AND
LIES, CHARACTER ASSASSINATION.
AS WE SPEAK THEY ARE DEPLOYING
THAT PLAYBOOK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I WARNED YOU.
WE SEE IT EVERY 2 YEARS AND
EVERY 4 YEARS.
ANY REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR
OFFICE IS A RACIST.
A SEXIST AND MISOGYNYIST.
THEY WANT DIRTY AIR AND WATER
AND KILL CHILDREN AND THROW
GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF.
ALL VOICES OF REASON IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY RAN OUT
OF THEIR PARTY JOE LIEBERMAN.
ONE OF THE NICEST GUYS IN THE
WORLD.
ALL MODERATION IS GONE.
THIS IS A FAR LEFT POLITICAL
PARTY.
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
JUST LISTEN TO THE DNC CHAIR.
HIS NAME IT TOM PEREZ.
BELOW HIM IS A GUY HE IS
DEFENDING.
KEITH ELLISON.
>> YOU SEE THE UNION MOVEMENT
ATTACKED BY REPUBLICANS.
THERE ARE NO GUARD RAILS IN
WASHINGTON.
WE KNOW THAT FOR SURE.
THERE ARE NO MODERATE
REPUBLICANS LEFT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Sean: I WILL BE HONEST.
I DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL.
I CAN'T PREDICT WHAT NEWS YOU
WILL HEAR 4 WEEKS FROM TONIGHT.
I AM CONCERNED FOR THE SAKE OF
THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T WANT THE GREAT PROGRESS
WE HAVE BEEN CHRONICLE
WE HAVE BEEN CHRONICING ON THIS
PROGRAM TO END.
I LIKE THE SECURITY AMERICA
LEADING THE WAY.
NOT LEADING FROM BEHIND.
I LIKE THAT WE ARE NOT TRYING TO
BRIBE DICTATORS THAT CHANT DEATH
TO AMERICA.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN IS NOT FIRING
ROCKETS OVER JAPAN EVERY OTHER
DAY.
I AM NOT CONFIDENT THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL HOLD THE HOUSE
OR THE SENATE OR PICK UP SEATS
IN THE SENATE.
OUR FRIEND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JASON TALKED ABOUT A NIGHTMARE
SCENARIO FOR THE COUNTRY.
IMAGINE WAKING UP ONE WEEK FROM
TOMORROW ON NOVEMBER SEVENTH,
THE DAY AFTER OUR ELECTION DAY
AND SEEING THE SOON TO BE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NANCY
PELOSI MEASURING DRAPES FOR HER
BRAND NEW OFFICE.
AND CHAIR WOMAN MAXINE WATERS
HEAD OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IMAGINE THE LIAR IN CHIEF, THE
CHAIRMAN TAKING CONTROL OF THE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
A GUY SCAMMED BY A RUSSIAN
HOAXSTER HIMSELF.
IMAGINE OF THE NEVER ENDING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO TRUMP AND
KAVANAUGH AND THE THIRST FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
KISS BORDER WALL FUNDING
GOOD-BYE.
PREPARE TO FORK OVER YOUR HARD
EARNED MONEY.
THEY WANT THEIR CRUMPS BACK.
DO YOU LIKE SKY ROCKETING
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
OBAMACARE THEY WANT TO KEEP
THAT.
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR AND PLAN AND
SAVE MONEY.
IS THIS WHAT YOU WANT.
THAT'S THE QUESTION YOU WILL
DECIDE 4 WEEKS FROM TONIGHT.
STARTING TONIGHT WE WILL PREVIEW
EACH KEY HOUSE RACE THAT WILL
DECIDE THE FATE OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
WE WILL HIGHLIGHT 10 IMPORTANT
RACES A NIGHT.
WE START ON THE WEST COAST
TONIGHT.
CALIFORNIA 10th CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN IN A
TIGHT REELECTION BID.
CALIFORNIA'S 21st DISTRICT, A
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT, HE IS
DOING WELL AGAINST THE DEMOCRAT
IN A DISTRICT WHERE HISANIC
AMERICANS MAKEUP 74% OF THE
DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA 25.
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN NAMED STEVE
KNIGHT IN A TOUGH KEY RACE
AGAINST HILL.
CALIFORNIA'S 39th DISTRICT.
REPUBLICAN AND A DEMOCRAT FACING
OFF IN A BATTLE FOR AN OPEN SEAT
VACATED.
THE DEMOCRAT IS SUFFERING IN THE
POLLS.
PERHAPS DUE TO AN ALLEGATION OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
CALIFORNIA 45, THE REPUBLICAN
INCUMBENT IS RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
IN 48th DISTRICT, A FRIEND OF
THIS PROGRAM.
DANA FACING A DEMOCRATIC
CHALLENGER.
AND CALIFORNIA'S 49th DISTRICT.
THAT'S A HOTLY CONTESTED RACE
BETWEEN THE REPUBLICAN AND THE
DEMOCRAT.
IN CALIFORNIA 50.
REPUBLICAN INCUMBENT UP IN AN
IMPORTANT RACE IN SANDING.
-- SAN DIEGO.
IN ARIZONA, DEMOCRAT UP FOR
REELECTION IN A DISTRICT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONLY CARRIED BY
1 POINT.
AND ARIZONA 2.
A VERY TIGHT RACE THERE FOR THE
SENATE.
THE REPUBLICAN IN THAT CASE
PETERSON IS RUNNING AGAINST THE
DEMOCRAT.
WE WILL POINT OUT 10 KEY RACES A
NIGHT.
YOU KNOW IF IT'S YOUR DISTRICT
THAT MATTERS.
THESE DISTRICTS WILL DECIDE THE
BALANCE OF POWER 4 WEEKS FROM
TONIGHT.
THE U.S. SENATE IS UP FOR GRABS.
MAYBE ANOTHER SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION OR TWO IN THE FUTURE.
YOU HAVE MONEY FROM BIG TIME
DEMOCRATIC BILLONAIRS PILING IN
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IN INDIANA A TIGHT RACE.
THAT'S A STATE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WON.
DONNELLY IS A SCHUMER DEMOCRAT.
AND ANOTHER SCHUMER DEMOCRAT IN
MISSOURI IS LOSING AFTER SHE
OPPOSED JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
NORTH DAKOTA.
DEMOCRAT HEIDI HEITKAMP WAY DOWN
IN THE POLLS AGAINST KRAMER.
IN TEXAS TED CRUZ IS POLLING
AHEAD.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT RACE.
IN TENNESSEE REPUBLICAN FRIEND
OF THIS PROGRAM, BLACKBURN IS
PICKING UP AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
VISIT.
AFTER THE VOTE FOR JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
AND MONTANA, THE DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT TIGHT RACE.
A CHANCE FOR A PICK UP IN
MONTANA THIS YEAR.
ARIZONA VERY, VERY TIGHT RACE.
AN AMERICAN HERO WHO SERVED OUR
COUNTRY.
I HOPE THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA PUT
HER IN THE SENATE.
WEST VIRGINIA AND DEMOCRAT JOE
MANCHIN THE ONLY DEMOCRAT TO
VOTE TO CONFIRM JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
MAYBE HE SHOULD SWITCH PARTIES.
HE WOULD WIN REELECTION.
JUST SAYING.
EACH NIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM WE
WILL BRING YOU AN UPDATE ON THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT MID-TERM
ELECTIONS IN OUR LIFETIME.
28 DAYS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE THE
PEOPLE, YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE THE POWER TO DECIDE ARE WE
GOING TO REWARD THE DISGUSTING
SMEAR TACTICS OF THE LEFT.
YOU WILL DECIDE IN THE ANGRY MOB
GETS THEIR WAY AND WHETHER OR
NOT NANCY PELOSI IS THE NEXT
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
WITH A BOOMING HISTORIC ECONOMY
AND SECURITY AT HOME AND ABROAD.
THE CHOICE TONIGHT COULD NOT BE
ANY MORE CLEAR.
4 WEEKS FROM TONIGHT!